why why would morbius be in the only way
i can see morbius being intrigued is if
he sincerely meant let's do some good
because that's who orbeez's character is
in this movie he would rather do some
good but if it is a setup for the
sinister six to do some bad
i'm like why would he be intrigued
what's intriguing about what he's heard
so far why is the question not
what do you mean what kind of good are
you talking about
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen of the reject
nation listen listen loud and clear we
have no interest in doing a morbius
spoiler talk
zero they did it for us they did it all
for us before it came out but here's
what we do want to talk about
the best post-credits scenes to have
ever existed in the history of marvel
that's right we just click baited you
with saying they're the worst we're here
to convince you that they're the best
ones ever played you played you idiots
click the like button and leave a
comment that's what you get for being
dumb yeah anyway
no these were the worst post-credits
scenes i think ever in marvel uh since
the mcu began i didn't think anything
can really top those amazing spider-man
2 ones with damn me these are magically
bad they are done themselves there's so
many things and so few things all at
once real quick recap of what happens in
morbius he's a doctor with a blood
condition ends up experimenting with
bats because who wouldn't and to then
find a way to you know cure himself
becomes a vampire along the way but it's
like i don't want to be a bad vampire
they'll end the movie okay that's pretty
much the film and then they do this they
cut to now both of the post crisis they
play between credits so i think they're
technically mid credit scenes but who's
who really says maker you guys want to
be like
technical semantic [ __ ] in the
comments people call them post credits
it cuts to the first post credit scene
it immediately turns into what i can
only describe as a sizzle reel for the
vulture spin-off movie like obviously
they're not going to make this vulture
spin-off movie because they they did it
all here
in 30 seconds or less the first thing
you see the breaking in the sky like oh
my god that's the doctor strange spell
no no way home that's what's happening
right now and then you see adrian tombs
michael keaton vulture transported into
a cell which raised some questions
already of
okay i thought the spell was supposed to
send people home even that even though
it's raising questions like okay
questions are fine i can roll with it
let's see what they do and then they
just screw it all up in like 10 seconds
the second freaking michael keaton gets
there
hope the food's better in this joint
it's like what that was my first time
like
a comic book guy of course he's unfazed
and it's just like
all right i'll adjust i guess i gotta
use this multiverse thing to my
advantage just to just he doesn't know
what's going on but sure well just i got
this under control i got records of my
existence here i'll just get out of jail
and go do stuff somehow felt very out of
character to me it didn't flow right it
didn't seem right no element of surprise
it seemed like they didn't tell michael
keaton what was going on we can't tell
him because it might ruin it just act a
little bit like just say this line it
felt that way to me adrian toombs man
who did everything for his family
and he's being transported to nowhere in
some like magical way yeah
you'd think he'd be a little freaked out
even the spider people were a little
freaked out like how did i get here
what's going on but adrian toombs
hope food's better in this joint you
know i built a suit once out of alien
technology i got this and then it cuts
to the news report footage right what
did i say on the news yeah they say
something about like oh adrian tombs he
claims he just showed up here there's a
high chance he's going to be led out of
jail basically i'm paraphrasing yeah
that he'll be released right away
because we don't know who he is yeah and
we're not gonna look into that and it
apparently just ends right there that's
scene one like what a stupid ass thing
and then it just started making me ask
more questions of what was the original
post-credits what was the original
inclusion it's like so obvious that when
he's transferred to the prison that's a
reshoot they inserted because this had
to come out after no way home now it
legit feels like there was a plot line
in the movie probably in the scene where
he was locked up and in the orange
jumpsuit where he probably would have
run into or met adrian tombs there that
they then took out of the movie and then
went what's like one or two of the most
important bullet points from that to get
the point across let's make that the
post-credits scene and then the second
post-credits scene
they outdid themselves i already thought
the first one was bad enough oh no cut
to morbius driving on
the highway where is he going where is
he when i thought he could fly now
i thought he flies he's saving his
energy for christ he gets called two in
the morning apparently he's like flying
under the radar now why would you be
speeding so fast in a car then wouldn't
you want to be flying what he's got
echolocation to sense cops you know so
apparently he feels like he's got some
type of threatening like there's a
threat coming then vulture comes flying
in he's got a suit now no one knows why
or how you're out no one knows how
impressive i am michael morbius he shows
up and then it just had me go what
message did he send morbius initially to
compel him to drive out at near three in
the morning
when he shows up and he's like this is a
this is a threatening situation not a
good one what message did he send him i
feel like it would be way easier to get
michael morbius on board with you if you
just contacted him as adrian tubes
honestly the biggest issue i had with
this scene is it felt out of character
for both of them and it was so apparent
they did not have the actors in the same
scene at least it felt that way it felt
like they had some voice over recordings
for michael keaton they had him do and
then they had jared leto do a few
reactionary takes and then they were
like well figured out an editing you
just put it in editing we'll figure it
out then it looks like they repurposed a
car commercial and then did a couple
shot reverse shots of jared leto in a
field and then made that the seat so the
first thing that michael keaton says is
like thanks for meeting with me doc it's
like this is not what is this what is
the toner is your familial banter here
thanks for being moved doc yeah
what is this he seemed like he like
called the meeting at like three in the
morning and it just seemed like such a
hey how's it going sorry to call you
here under such weird circumstances
can't be too careful and then he says i
don't know how i got here i think it has
something to do with spiderman
it's just like such a bad dialogue then
it just further drove home that point it
further drove home like why is he just
adjusting to here and not trying to
figure out how to get home to his wife
and kid like why is he not trying to
figure any of this out and again why
would vulture want to set up a sinister
six instead of trying to figure out how
to get back home like what's the motive
here exactly and then to make things
more confusing he goes on to say i'm
thinking that you and i and a couple
other people like us we could put
together a team do some good do some
good and then morbius is just like
intriguing i'm gonna do this
and i'm like wait wait there's a whole
character turn in here and a whole bunch
of other mumbo jumbo that we have no
context for for either of them in this
situation and it's just more confusing
because is it like real good or
sarcastic good yeah like do some good
like oh we can make good money do like
criminal yeah activities or is are they
going to try to make the sinister six
like a team of good there's a dirty
dozen thirty half dozen now why why
would morbius be in the only way i can
see morbius being intrigued is if he
sincerely meant let's do some good
because that's who orbeez's character is
in this movie he would rather do some
good but if it is a setup for the
sinister six to do some bad
i'm like why would he be intrigued
what's intriguing about what he's heard
so far why is the question not
what do you mean what kind of good are
you talking about because you just
presented me a display of power rather
than a display of intention evelyn's you
know that shouldn't end intriguing so
you should end on
what are you talking about and how is
venom gonna figure into that too because
you know he's going to be part of that
team and venom is a character already
established to want to do a little good
actual good whereas like the vulture
that doesn't seem like the mo yet at all
they've questioned the rules of the
spell which is something i think they
can explain away a little bit better
that seems like it's a combination of a
bunch of deleted things it didn't feel
real
like
it does feel like it was made a couple
days ago it really does it felt like a
marketing team put together something
last minute let's make some
readjustments let's let's let's do it
like this so what are some discarded
takes we can use let's just figure
something out based on that it seemed
like they didn't tell geraldo any
direction and they were like just do it
a few times we'll see which one's best
for this and same thing with michael
keaton like it really got the sense that
michael kitten didn't even know what he
was talking about the whole setup is
just confusing goes against character
for both of them in so many ways i
thought they were poorly put together
poorly executed
confusing funny for all the wrong
reasons and uh they feel like a weird
micro movie
and they make the previous whole movie
you just saw feel worse for having yes
is i think part of it too give it up
sony keep it up really excited for
whatever
six movie turns out to be i thought that
is so much worse of a sinister six setup
and the director confirms what he's
doing that is so much worse of a
sinister six setup than what the amazing
spider-man 2 did yeah like that was like
oh god brother when that happened but at
least in some way they established that
there's shady things they're building
here at oscar yeah here this just just
comes out of nowhere yes nowhere
so bad
and it all harkens toward a sinister six
that's actually just a team of is just
the suicide squad or something a team of
anti-heroes who ultimately are not gonna
be allowed to be that sinister
anyway guys leave your thoughts down
below
do you love it
[Laughter]
[Music]